thank you guys for having me here I
actually started my career at Stanford
with computers
is Department I used to be opposed to a
cure for one year few years ago with
your Alaska vets and then I moved to the
Graduate School of Business which is not
really about business it turns out I
have a lot of academic freedom there no
one really cares don't tell them that I
said that no one really cares what I'm
doing something that is directly related
to business I got I got freedom to push
through whatever questions I'm
interested in so it's not as bad as they
tell you at the computer science
department and I'll be talking today
about the end of privacy it's not going
to be a technical talk I'm not using
anything too complicated
most of my papers are based on linear
regressions or logistic regressions
maybe an occasional pre-trained deep
neural network but nothing too fancy and
also I do enjoy questions I think that
we can all learn the most if the
audience is somewhat and engage in the
talk and also it's my favorite part I've
already heard this talk before so I
would really enjoy if you guys stopped
me if I'm going too fast or too slow or
I said something you agree or disagree
with and let me start with a short intro
and I'm sure here you guys know better
than and then I do that we're leaving an
enormous amount of digital footprints
behind when using digital products and
services your smartphone is recording
your location accelerometer units can
record your heartbeat it knows where you
get go to bed and when you wake up it
knows whom you're dating it knows how
well the date went it knows your
geographical location it knows the
context and the contents of your
communication with other people and your
smartphone is just one of the devices
that is recording your behavior think
about your Fitbit or any other fitness
tracker that you're using think about
your car if you have a modern car it's
likely that it's going to be connected
with its producer duty recording
data on your driving and whereabouts and
when you are using it and where you are
going and we are producing an enormous
amount of data in this way every single
day
back in 2012 IBM estimated that an
average person is generating 500
megabytes of data every single day now
to help you imagine how much data it is
let's have a thought experiment here
imagine you wanted to back it up on
paper letter-sized Times New Roman size
12 single lines double-sided how tall
would be a stack of paper that contains
just one day worth of data that humanity
is producing or used to be producing in
2012 / humanity
one day worth of data back in 2012 to
meet Jupiter's more than what Jupiter is
the what is the Jupiter distance between
the Sun and Jupiter were the size of
Jupiter what more than that's it the
stack of paper will be like from here to
the Sun four times over and it's back in
2012 and now we are producing more data
recently The Economist estimated that in
2025 an average person living on earth
will be producing 62 gigabytes of data
and we are going to have more people so
you cannot really back it up on paper we
used it all already on the back up in
2012 if you wanted to break it up on
DVDs 5 gigabytes per DVD one millimeter
per DVD the stack of DVDs would be 105
thousand kilometers one quarter of away
from here to the moon biggest drive was
30 gigabytes in - and in the year 2000
they got up 260 and 2004 that's great
progress I actually the next slide
should be I removed it from this
presentation should be Amazon snowmobile
do you guys know what I was in
snowmobile is
it's Amazon's response the portable hard
drive is a track that can carry I forgot
actually how much data it can carry but
it takes 10 days to load it up and you
would need hundreds of those to backup
all of the humanities data in back in
2012 the bottom line is we're producing
an enormous amount of data every single
day and now the question is what can we
do with this data now well depends on
whom you ask if you ask someone working
for a credit-card company they will say
tell you well we can sell this data and
this is how we are funding this our
operations credit-card company started
as financial services companies and this
is what this used to be their main line
of business if you talk to the
representatives of Visa or MasterCard
today you would hear that they see
themselves now as a consumer inside
companies this is why they are so eager
to pay you money for using the credit
your credit card simply you are the
product now in the day and the data are
creating and this data is being sold to
other institutions and other companies
and essentially I'm sure you heard this
saying before that if you're not paying
for a product or a service then guess
what you're a product with data of
behavior yes and we're also getting a
lot in return we're getting all of those
search engines and Google Maps and
social networks and arguably those
services are making our lives in many
ways better but I also bring and
introduce some additional risks ok but
I'm a psychologist so I'm not going to
talk about credit cards I'm not going to
talk about the progress in healthcare
that a big data is driving I'm not going
to talk about self-driving cars are
going to and probably already are saving
lives and their self-driving mechanisms
are also based on all of this data we're
generating today what I will be talking
today about is how we can learn more
about humans and human psychology and
predict future behavior you
doing all of these digital footprints
that we are generating every day and one
of the first studies I've conducted in
this space back in 2011-2012 was using
it one of the online environments
Facebook and I used Facebook Likes in
this particular study Facebook Likes
that were donated to me by the
participants in my research we had a
questionnaire online that allowed you to
take some personality questionnaires am
IQ question as happiness survey report
on your political views and bunch of
other things and then you could also
donate your Facebook profile data to our
research project and around 40 percent
of our participants did that we had over
6 million participants we we got a very
decent database containing detailed
profile information Facebook profile
information and psychometric scores of a
very large number of people and at that
time in fact back in 2011-2012 if you
asked a psychologist whether studying
Facebook data can be useful in
in the context of psychological science
they would say of course not because
when people go on Facebook they suddenly
change and you know they become unicorns
or for the old guys become suddenly
sixteen-year-old girls and there's no
continuity no consistency between your
behavior in the online setting and
offline setting and now I think that
most of us who use internet a bit more
and know a bit about it understand that
this is not entirely true that of course
in different environments would put
different masks on and change our
behavior a bit but generally I think
it's pretty clear now that who we are
online is highly consistent with who we
are offline in fact one could argue that
those two spaces offline and online are
increasingly overlapping right if you're
walking around with your smartphone and
the smartphone is recording your
location or communication with others is
it's really you being online or offline
right it's very difficult to say bye
back at that time this question was
still open so one of my first projects
was to see whether we can predict the
real life outcomes offline outcomes and
those outcomes in psychology will be
defined as your personality is measured
by a personality questionnaire or your
political views your religiosity and so
on from your online behavior and the
underlying assumption was that if we can
take your online behavior and predict
your offline outcomes the derma on a
large scale for many people there must
be some consistency between both of them
and by the way when I told my supervisor
at that time and the Department of
Psychology that I'm going to be studying
Facebook
he literally faced palmed and said look
I'm giving up on even never going to get
a job and there's no future for
psychology in this type of research ok
so to make a long story short we took
Facebook Likes Facebook Likes are one of
the most generic types of digital
footprint or essentially connections
between a user and some kind of digital
object in this case it might be a
Facebook page or a book or
movie or a picture of a funny goat that
your friend posted on Facebook so we
took those connections between users and
their likes and try to build predictive
models aiming at their their real-life
outcomes
psychological traits political views and
so on methodology used in this work was
really simple pca time in china tea
reduction on the user like matrix and
then linear or logistic regression so
there's nothing fancy about it and in
fact we did it on purpose first of all
it helps you to publish more easily and
it's easier to communicate especially in
pop science journals like p and is it
allows you to communicate more easily
with journalists or psychologists who
are not as technologically savvy as
people at the computer science
department but also we found that even
if you use very fancy methods neural
networks support vector machines and so
on accuracy would go up but it wouldn't
go up by much it seems it seemed to us
and it's something that is i think will
be pretty clear to most of you guys that
if you have enough data even a
relatively simple method will give you
good results
in building predictive models and I've
been talking for way too long let me now
show you a short a video clip that
presents the results of this study that
we conducted back in 2012 thinking the
University of Cambridge over in London
actually did a study of what people like
on Facebook to try to determine facts
about them that they wouldn't otherwise
know so they didn't just look at the
products the the movies the bands that
people like they also looked at the
status updates that people liked the
photos that people liked and they were
able to draw some really really
interesting and conclusions about all of
your likes that you're clicking can tell
more about you than you might have
realized from your political values to
your religion to your gender to your
happiness your age in fact some parts of
your identity can be predicted with
95% accuracy accuracy was Louis about
60% when it came to predicting whether a
user's parents were still together when
they're 21 people whose parents divorced
before they're 21 tended to like
statements about relationships drug
users were ID'd with about 65 percent
accuracy smokers with 73 percent and
drinkers with 70 percent sexual
orientation was also easier to
distinguish among men 88 percent right
there for women it was about 75 percent
gender by the way race religion and
political views were predicted with high
accuracy as well for instance white
versus black ninety-five percent the
findings have alarmed privacy
campaigners who fear this research could
be used to commercially exploit users so
keep in mind that just because you think
you're not revealing a lot of personal
details on Facebook you're still
spreading the word to the outside world
as well as those online marketers
volunteers with few friends liked
walking with your friend and randomly
pushing them into someone or something
hey it's not their fault they don't have
friends everyone they know keeps getting
randomly pushed into traffic
high IQ corresponds to liking Mozart
science and The Colbert Report
search indicated people who like Harley
Davidson motorbikes are generally of low
IQ
we thought we'd better offer a right to
reply I say our average customer is
probably more intelligent than most and
we're sitting at a lot of customers who
are people from Cambridge University for
start a like on Facebook can reveal if
you're a gay man yeah especially if what
you choose to like is penises
that's my wife walking animal joke by
the way don't be an idiot and think that
if somebody clicked on wicked the
musical that they're you a automatically
or they clicked on harley-davidson and
it was stupid automatically ironically
that would make you stupid okay so as
you guys can see you can take those
seemingly innocent pieces or types of
digital footprints such as Facebook
Likes and use this information to reveal
a broad range of very intimate traits of
Facebook users with relatively high
accuracy and now Facebook Likes are by
far not the most revealing type of
digital footprints there are many things
you would do and never reveal it on
Facebook to your friends there are many
websites you are visiting from time to
time that you would never like on
Facebook like let's say technical
documentation you wouldn't share you
know the fact they wouldn't like my cql
technical documentation on Facebook and
yet it will be very revealing
potentially about your psychological
traits there are many things you would
search for using Google that you would
and not mention to your closest friend
not to mention that you probably tend to
forget about some things that you google
from time to time because it's so
intimate or embarrassing or or whatnot
so what I'm arguing here is that all of
those predictions it can be based on
Facebook Likes are most likely there are
studies proving that point are
essentially conservative estimate of how
much one can learn about you from your
digital footprints and now the important
point here is that of course if you go
online and state your political
preferences or reveal your sexual tation
or post the result of your personality
questionnaire there or email it to
someone then well you don't need to be
an Einstein to understand that's now
Google Facebook or whatever other
environment and bunch of marketers and
your GSM operator and the producer of
your phone they would all know they
would all have access to this
information
but what's important here is that it's
enough to just look at the pictures of
goats that you liked on Facebook or the
books you have read and you may have
never mentioned what your political
affiliation was and still this
information can be gleaned using an
argument algorithm revealed using an
algorithm from those seemingly innocent
Facebook Likes so now the question is of
course how does the prediction model
work and this joke works with
psychological audiences because I
usually say and now we'll run you
through this equation but actually in
this room I'm sure that you guys could
run me through this a question and let's
not do this let me give you one
practical example here imagine there is
the anonymous user and you know nothing
about them the only thing you know about
this anonymous user is that they like
Hello Kitty the brand now can you tell
me what would be the gender of this
anonymous user seem a very judgmental
and yet very accurate judgemental
because it turns out that the person who
is the most Hello Kitty toys in the
world is this retired Japanese gentleman
but then of course you're accurate when
you look at official Facebook statistics
related to Hello Kitty the brand you can
see that 99 percent of users that liked
Hello Kitty on Facebook are in fact
females and they're all so young so if
you knew nothing about this anonymous
user it would be a safe bet to say that
there are female now what would be their
career would they be in the military or
in sales sales of course well done you
can see that Hello Kitty fans are
overrepresented there would they use a
PC or an iPhone iPhone of course there's
nearly no-one they're liking Hello Kitty
and using a PC so now you can see that
you don't need to be an algorithm or a
computer scientist or even a
psychologist to take just one like of an
anonymous user and make a broad range of
quite accurate psycho demographic
predictions now of course typically this
task is not as easy take Forrest Gump
for instance if I told you look this
anonymous user liked Forrest Gump you
probably would have much it will be much
more difficult to make a prediction what
the gender is why because everyone likes
Forrest Gump both men and women right
but when you look at the details you can
still see that there is a slight over a
presentation of men among people who
liked Forrest Gump and by the way also
you can see that older people are
overrepresented which means that if you
reveal to an algorithm that you if you
reveal to me that you like Forrest Gump
I probably wouldn't be able to make an
accurate prediction now if you reveal
this information to an algorithm
algorithm will be able to update its
beliefs about what your gender age and
bunch of other traits is and of course
this prediction is not deterministic
here but as you reveal more and more
data if you can look at hundreds of
thousands of left behind you get a very
high accuracy it's a great question this
plot comes from Facebook I would have to
look at it for a bit longer to answer
this question this that's certainly a
key to to those numbers ok so you guys
know how it works and why it works now
the question is how accurate are those
predictions and let us just stick to
Facebook Likes for now this plot shows
you the relationship between number of
Facebook likes that you reveal to an
algorithm and again an algorithm is just
a combination of singular value
decomposition and linear regression it's
the simplest predictive algorithm you
can come up with for the task of this
kind and you can see that the more likes
to reveal to an algorithm the more
accurate the prediction of your score on
a personality questionnaire would be the
accuracy is expressed as a correlation
and now if we had any psychologists in
the room or even better any
psychometricians in the room I would
expect some louse here because this plot
shows that those perdy
are really accurate the accuracy of the
questionnaire itself is not higher than
0.7 on maybe point 8 in some cases so
essentially if you have the person a
person take the same personality
questionnaire two times let's say in a
space of a month the score on the first
take would predict the score in the
second take with an accuracy of about
0.72 point eight which essentially means
that we are reaching the accuracy of the
questioner itself if we reveal around
three hundreds a bit more Facebook Likes
to the algorithm let me and then try to
explain illustrate the accuracy of those
algorithms using another comparison
let's compare the accuracy of the
algorithm when predicting your responses
to a personality questionnaire or your
personality scores with an accuracy of
another very accurate way of judging
your personality other people we are
walking personality prediction machines
we evolved to be very good at judging
other people's personality and in fact
if I showed you a five second video of a
person you'd be able to judge their
personality their extraversion
neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness and open-mindedness
which is a proxy for the political views
with some accuracy you wouldn't be
terribly accurate but you'll be
significantly better than random okay so
what we did in this study we gave people
personality questioners and we asked
them to fill in those personality
questionnaires but not in their own name
but in the name of their acquaintances
or friends basically we asked them to
anticipate the responses of other people
so now how many Facebook Likes do you
need to reveal to an algorithm for the
algorithm to be as accurate at judging
your personality as your work colleagues
any guesses eight great guess it's ten
in fact now to which the accuracy of
your friends and family members you need
to reveal to an algorithm slightly more
information between 60 and 100 likes and
now the most accurate of human judges
your own spouse
can be outperformed by a very simple
equation that can look at around 240 250
of your facebook likes now this is
really remarkable your spouse's arguably
know you really well they spend a lot of
time with you they've seen you across
many different situations you had
intimate conversations with them you
shared your histories your stories they
have insight into the way you think if
you got married recently they still pay
a lot of attention to you there is a
very good connection between you guys
and now we ask this spouse to predict
your response to a questions on put on a
personality questionnaire such as I like
poetry or I'm always attending I'm
always on time
on them at the meetings or I like
reading books or I like hanging out with
friends in the restaurants or bars those
are essentially types of questions
you'll be asked when you're feeling a
personality questionnaire and now you
would assume that your spouse having
spent a lot of time with you would be
great at anticipating your responses to
these questions again it turns out the
240 likes and a simple equation and an
algorithm can predict those responses
better than your spouse which
essentially is predicting your future
behavior right because you're responding
to the questions on a questionnaire is a
type of behavior it turns out we showed
in other studies that computers will be
also better at predicting not only your
responses to the questionnaire but also
other behaviors such as purchase
behaviors or choosing and the holiday
destination that you will go to in the
future and so on there isn't a lot of
poetry to like so I think my spouse
would be able to predict whether I like
poetry better than my Facebook like
history would predict that word did you
extract that actual like history through
some kind of survey of the participants
and that's precisely my point that you
don't need to like anything related to
poetry on Facebook you don't need to
anything related to your political views
or your sexual orientation or your
personality in a direct way on Facebook
and still the patterns of you liking
goats and cats and baby pictures that
your friends post on Facebook would
allow an algorithm to predict your
response to a question about poetry
better than your own wife could ever
could so those models are trained in a
completely data-driven way so what we're
taking we're taking in this case in the
case of this study we take 60,000 people
and we take with responses of these
60,000 people to a personality
questionnaire and one of the questions
there would be I like poetry and you can
strongly disagree or strongly agree with
this question and everything in between
and then we take these peoples Facebook
Likes and we hide 10% of this sample
from a computer we use 90% to train the
model to run its predictions and then we
test these predictions and the remaining
holdouts test sample to check how
accurate the model was and then we can
compare it with the accuracy of people
when predicting your scores on a
personality questionnaire okay and those
models as you guys have all might have
heard recently are not just explored in
in my lab and other people's labs but
are increasingly used out there by
governments and corporations to improve
your experience in the online different
online environments or reveal your
intimate rates without your consent and
permission and also highly encourage you
to go to this website apply magic sauce
comm it's hosted by Cambridge University
and there you can check what predictions
can be made based on your Facebook Likes
the models used there are based on this
research that we conducted back in 2013
okay and as I said before Facebook Likes
are by far not the only type of digital
footprints you can use in running these
predictions in fact other types of
digital footprints are not
only more easily accessible like credit
card records a web browsing history so
search logs can be accessed much more
easily by academics companies and
governments and they reveal way more
information and I won't be talking too
much about these studies as they are
very similar to the study that I've just
described based on Facebook Likes but
the curious will be getting there are
usually much higher my favorite type of
digital footprint is language it's so
pervasive we live language on Twitter
status in the Facebook status updates we
live language in our emails or it can be
transcribed from our conversations by
your Alexa or Google a smart home or
whatever it's called or by your Siri on
on your phone and so on so we are now
collecting a lot of language data and
turns out that language is also very
revealing about your intimate traits
here what you can see you can see two
word clouds presenting words there were
most predictive of high and low levels
of personality trait of openness this
trade by the way is nearly synonymous
with your political views so basically
people high in openness are liberal and
people low in openness are conservative
and then to vote for conservative
candidates and again those models are
being now widely used in practical
applications this is a screenshot from
IBM Watson that offers an API that can
turn samples of language into accurate
predictions of psychological Endemol
graphic traits of people who contributed
a given sample of text and Microsoft
cognitive services Amazon Cloud in this
bunch of other services also do the same
for you education sure so in a way bias
very often is what an algorithm were not
very often essentially the fact that
women tend to use certain word more
often is what an algorithm would pick on
to make a prediction to be able to
predict your gender when it looks at
your language that's not an uncharged
word so to describe what's found and
then to integrate that into the term
hedonism which was one of the things
that diagram is something that there's
an implicit judgement I see okay so I
think that's yes that's a great point
but it's being a word that has a lot of
intrinsic judgment in it but it's not
that the scientists sit down and say or
people that I be emotion say oh let's
call these people high on hedonism there
is a group of researchers surely out
there and actually I'm not an expert in
hedonism myself at least theoretically
but there's a bunch of scientists there
who decided there is that mention of
hedonism and it can be studied and they
were producing books and papers on it
and they also design a psychometric
scale and then they measured his head on
hedonism using the psychometric scale so
what happens here is that IBM Watson in
fact it's based on the work of Jamie
Pennebaker that Jamie Pennebaker would
take a lot of people would measure their
hedonism using an established
psychometric scale and we can call it
dimension alpha it doesn't really matter
right they it measures some
psychological dimension that a bunch of
psychologists thought was relevant and
important to predict some future
behaviors and then matched basically
train the model predicting it's your
score hidden is from the language is
something this is highly charged as that
it has implications in terms of how the
data is going to be used and what the
impact of it's going to be and that's
something that I find kind of
interesting and slightly problematic now
the entry that's a great point again an
interesting thing is that I is a
psychologist when I community
with audiences I'm expected to tell you
how well an algorithm can predict
personality now if you really ask me if
I think it's important I don't think
it's important at all because why would
we waste time having an algorithm
predicting our personality if we can
have an algorithm try to predict our
actual behavior at the end of the day
person psychologists came up with
personality to be able to predict future
behavior but now you can train a train
algorithms that go directly from well
your past behavior or Facebook like
status updates but not into predicting
your future behavior are you likely to
vote are you likely to buy this product
are you likely to commit a crime or
whatever else you want to predict while
keeping all of those human assign labels
entirely because in the world of AI who
cares so those are percentiles so it
shows in my agreeableness is 30 which
means that I'm more agreeable than 30
percent of people or more disagreeable
than 69 percent of people when it comes
to measures like when you come to when
it comes to scales like personality
there are deliberately designed to
measure a concept are stable and in fact
there's a lot of evidence that if you
measure personality of six year olds or
five year olds then teenagers and then
people who are 80 that the rank order
would be stable so of course you have
some changes in personality across the
lifetime let me give you my favorite
example which is conscientiousness even
the least conscientious adult is
probably way more conscientious than any
five-year-old right because the brain
has a chance to develop and the
conscientiousness had a chance to
self-control impulse control and whatnot
but what happens is that when you look
at the rank order so you have a kid that
is top of their class when it comes to
conscientiousness the kid would be also
an adult there is top of their cohort
when it comes to conscientiousness and
because those dimensions dimensions of
personality would be essentially decided
designed and defined as dimensions that
should not change across your lifetime
and then you have other dimensions such
as mood that would vary from day to day
and even other dimensions like emotion
that can change from one second to
another second Zook and you can measure
all of these using this type of data is
just you would use different data right
if use Facebook Likes that crew on your
profile over many years this is not the
best way of measuring your emotion you
probably should use Twitter or some data
from sensors in your smartphone now when
you look at those more permanent traits
such as intelligence or personality they
are not changing with time then you can
use data like samples of language or of
course 99 great measures I want is the
percentage of you silly great majority
of the uses of such data is for the
benefit of the human kind and and us as
individuals and we were doing it for the
longest time
look recruitment you have one way one
way of recruiting people which is I will
give a job to my friends and also give a
job to people who look nice and were
born to wealthy families which were
doing for the most of the human history
and we still doing or maybe I should
give a job to people who are most
capable of doing this job or the same
relates to places at the universities
this is why we have entrance exams to
avoid hiring kids of the wealthy only we
still hire kids of the wealthy in a
overrepresented around here and in other
places but we are using a
ability tests to find also kids that
were not likely to be born in a wealthy
family but have a potential and
capability to achieve a lot when a given
opportunity to study and interestingly
IQ tests which are completely vilified
in America which always surprises
Europeans because essentially IQ tests
were developed to circumvent the problem
of privileged people snitching all of
the jobs and stitching all of the spots
in the educational system an idea of the
IQ test is that it doesn't ask you about
your knowledge because of course you've
had a private tutor you will have more
knowledge it doesn't ask you it's tries
to avoid using language and asking
questions even to give a chance to
immigrants like me where I cannot
compete with a local kid when it comes
to the vocabulary but it would use those
very basic types of tasks for your brain
like mental rotations of pattern
recognition which kind of shows you the
kind of this how strong your CPU in your
brain is and then based on that you can
predict and actually IQ score is the is
a single single number is the best known
predictor of the very broad or the
broadest range of real life outcomes
ranging from your health and longevity
through your success at work success in
academia income and great number of
other outcomes and now if we can predict
your personality your IQ if we can
predict your potential of begetting a
depression if we can predict your
potential of committing a suicide from
digital footprints this means that we
can bring the benefits of Education job
person match psychological diagnosis a
prevention of people committed from
committing suicide to people who are
deprived of it at the moment if you come
from the privileged environment and you
have psycho therapies that you can
always call and spend 200 bucks per hour
or whatever however you spend however
much you spend you do not need any of
this to be happy in life now if you come
from the developing country where the
places that the universities are limited
where the
system recruitment system is corrupt
where you do not have access to
psychological current diagnosis then
being able to predict your risk of
suicide or your risk of depression or
Matthew with a job using your digital
footprint and the time of an algorithm
is really cheap compared with a time of
a psychologist this is a life-changing
exercise for potentially billions of
people and it does it answer your
question at all or thank you okay we
should we should point out that the
statute Binet intelligence test was
developed here by German the dad of a
founder of the department I should say
the School of Engineering but this
raises some questions in chat who were
farming in the areas and some where are
you going to be touching on the basis of
things like mass comm and eHarmony and
tinder or all of that as well - very
good state I mean I'm also expecting to
match this with traditional psychometric
such as the Minnesota multiphasic
personality inventory as well - and okay
well of course I could and the question
is why no it's not a part of my
presentation so we just focus on Big
Five here and just it's an example we
had some we had IQ satisfaction of life
scale depression scales and whatnot so
the bottom line is it the bottom line
actually is pretty intuitive if there is
an important psychological or
demographic property of yours that
affects your behavior guess what by
looking at your behavior I'll be able to
predict it right so if it's an NPI or IQ
whatever other scale you want to look at
it would be predictable from digital
footprints sometimes you just need to
find right type of a digital footprint -
for a given task and there was another
questionnaire in the back that the
trades over time shaved out nature
versus nurture
oh that's a great question and probably
for a very different talk most of their
essentially again our essential
psychological traits that are considered
to be stable like intelligence and when
I say stable I usually mean rank order
because you're sure IQ the operating
power of your brain maxes out at sixteen
seventeen and this is why checker
players when you look at the
championships those people who when
winning checkers that usually sixteen
seventeen and then the sure operating
power of your brain goes down from there
what increases user experience and
skills and all of this lag baggage of
thoughts that you had and problems that
you already solved in your head and
memorize the solution this is called
crystallized intelligence and this grows
up until I forgot exactly what it was
fifty years or something until you start
forgetting more than you then you
learned this is why chess players peak
if I remember correctly at thirty
something yeah their CPU is not as fast
as it used to be when they were sixteen
but they managed to memorize many more
games but by at that time and again
there are other traits that are much
more changeable with time and I won't go
into nature versus nurture debate
because essentially from the modern
psychology point of view it's no debate
because they are so intertwined that I'm
not sure why would anyone see nature
versus nature as conflicting two
conflicting issues we can talk about it
more in the next section of my talk
simulation work too hard to say I don't
know what Alexandra Cogan is doing apart
from you know he's claiming has done or
not done and he definitely has no
interest in telling the truth given that
okay so one yet another type of digital
footprints that it's really is really
interesting is digital images of our
faces and as you guys realize we are
living an enormous amount of pictures of
our faces selfies profile pictures CC
signal from the CCTV
cameras online while using knowingly or
unknowingly digital products and
services and when I and essentially what
I will try to convince you to is that
you can use faces you can use digital
images of faces to reveal intimates
traits of people when I say that there's
usually a lot of pushback especially
it's sociology or psychology departments
people say how dare you saying that one
can judge anything from a person's face
but wait a moment we make a lot of
judgments based on people's faces we can
easily judge other people's gender based
on their face and age by the way and and
gender and age our psycho demographic
variables your gender is not just a
demographic variable it also affects
your choices and preferences and
behaviors emotion is an intimate
psychological state and yet no one in
this room would have any trouble judging
other people's emotions from their faces
but actually even when people try to act
like try to hide their emotion we still
are able to judge their emotion from
their face genes being able to spot
twins or recognize similarity between
parents and children are essentially
making judgments related to genotype
based on someone's face and it also
relates to genetic disorders many of
which can be revealed inferred from
someone's face even by an untrained eye
and then if you have a trained eye like
if you're a physician you'll be trained
to recognize a broad range of genetic
and developmental disorders political
views which of those guys voted for
Trump well we wouldn't know for sure but
you probably would have some
see in your guesses here and this is
because and I'm sorry for what happens
on this slide I think I created it on
Mac and it doesn't rework with PC very
well this was supposed to be an icon of
a brain and this was supposed to be an
icon of your face this is because there
are at least three mechanisms that link
your face and your facial features with
your behavior and psychological traits
and the first mechanism goes from this
beautiful icon of a brain to the
beautiful icon of your face the first
mechanism is that your face effect your
behavior and psychological traits and
let me give you just the simplest
example here the attractiveness of your
face is going to affect your
extraversion how friendly and social you
are from the moment you're born if you
happen to be a beautiful baby your mom
is going to smile more at you sounds
very unfair this is a fact you go to
school other kids want to hang out with
you more they give you more positive
feedback they want to be around you
because you're attractive you graduate
from school you will find spouses more
easy to find a job more easily
you'll be voted for more easily if
you're a presidential candidate or a
political candidate you are more likely
to get a pay rise and so on you're
getting constant rewards from
interacting with other people because
you're pretty guess what you will
develop more bubbly warm friendly
personality because you're getting so
much encouragement for from from
interacting with other people now
another interesting result of being
attractive you're likely to be you're
you're more likely to be conservative
why well we don't really know but it
turns out that conservatives are more
tend to be more attractive when it comes
to their facial features as judged by
other people the suggested explanation
of this phenomenon is that if you are
more attractive you things come more
easily to you in life you get promotion
more easily you're less likely to be
unemployed and so on which reduces
your appreciation of supporting others
and this is why you are a lot more
likely to be conservative and I had
example of attractiveness there now of
course there also met there's also
another mechanism which is your
psychological traits and your behaviors
will affect your face fashion is one
example you tend to hang out with other
people there are psychologically similar
to you and there's a lot of evidence for
homophily when it comes to intelligent
political views gender age and a number
of other things now guess what if you
hang out with these people you're likely
to develop some signals that you belong
to a given group we call it fashion if
fashion will be expressed on your faces
well your facial hair do you her do your
makeup
tattoos another other what we'll call
them earrings thank you and so on
another example if you have an outdoorsy
if you're an outdoorsy type you have
psychology that kind of predisposes you
to hang out a lot of spend a lot of time
outdoors guess what will happen again it
will show on your face for instance in
the form of a Sun Tan and now there are
factors as well factors that affect both
your face and your behavior so this is a
third mechanism here and a simplest one
is testosterone we very well understand
the results that the stas Cerrone has on
your behavior we can study it by giving
people shots of testosterone and seeing
how their behavior changes are you
becoming more socially dominant you're
becoming more aggressive now we also
know what effects testosterone has on
your face exposure to higher levels of
testosterone across lifetime will reduce
the amount of collagen underneath your
skin and as half of the audience here it
seems to be suffering from it as well it
will also increase raise your hairline
alright so we have a factor that affects
both your face
and your psychological traits which
essentially means that and I think I
mentioned I already mentioned those
things that there are strong links
between faces and psychological traits
now some of them like gender we are
great at detecting so we can easily
predict gender from from face other
psychological traits are very difficult
for us to read from other people's faces
let me give you an example if I ask you
which of these psychologists here is
more extroverted you probably actually
in fact the studies show that you'll be
slightly better than random you would
not be completely random you'll be
slightly better than random at judging
which of these faces belongs to the more
extroverted person but you're a curious
would be really low and now the question
is is it that your extraversion is not
communicated through your face or is not
linked with your facial features or is
it that our brain did not evolve a
capacity to either perceive or interpret
the relevant signal that reveals your
level of extraversion now it turns out
that is the ladder and let me show you
an evidence of that what you can see
here is 10 images of introverted women
and 10 images of extroverted women
overlaid on top of each other there's
not no computer vision magic here is
just 10 images overlaid on top of each
other and now no one here would have any
problem with judging which of these
groups which of these 10 images
represents in introvert and which one
represents extroverted women as you can
see glasses no glasses no smiling
smiling on extroverted side better heard
1 the extrovert it's arguably dyed hair
if you look more closely you could also
see in a color a colorful version of
this image that extroverted women tend
to have blue eyes now there's no reason
to believe that having blue eyes makes
you more extroverted but they most
likely are wearing contact lenses now if
you look more closely you would also see
that the shapes of facial facial
features differ
of the nose width of the face shape of
the jaw would differ between introverted
and extroverted individuals those
differences are really small when you
just look at the and the individual
faces but when you overlay them on top
of each other which amplifies the signal
suddenly the difference big differences
become clear another question here you
can see that introverted women have
nostrils whereas extroverted women have
no nostrils can anyone guess why
extroverted women have no nostrils
they're moving more no that's not the
correct answer great if you'd say if
you're going to take one thing from this
talk here remember that if you know
anything about taking selfies you take
selfies from above like this your face
will look better extroverted and people
know a lot about this but then also your
nostrils would not be visible now it
turns out that when you train deep
neural networks to predict personality
from from human face the accuracy is
comparable with the accuracy of your
work colleague so it's not yet the
accuracy of your spouse judging a
personality but it's already a very
decent accuracy out there by the way in
the world in occupational context
actually work colleagues are very often
used to judge each other's personality
this is because if you give people
personality questionnaires in the
occupational context those scores tend
to be very highly unreliable because
people tend to lie while responding to
them because they realize that there
will be some decisions made in the
future based on their scores so this is
why in occupational context we use cross
ratings to measure people's personality
very often and it turns out that a
computer algorithm can achieve the same
accuracy just based on the image of your
face and again those are not technical
technologies are not limited just the
lab you have a screenshot here from
Microsoft cognitive services judging
your emotion from the picture of your
face so psychological traits from the
states from a picture of the face
it's just surreal I mean something in
the ancient China and in the induct in
the culture they there are something
called with new things and like what
type of shapes and predictive predict
the fate of some kind personality of
this person and it seems like this has
been studied for thousands of years the
people just keep getting to the similar
Sigma inches in this so we have the same
tradition in in the Western culture it's
called physiognomies and there were
plenty of pretty famous scientist in
fact that we're big believers in the
ability of revealing your traits and
character from your face now it's pretty
clear now that physiognomies was that
their judgments were not accurate that
it was just thinly it was essentially
just a cover for for a bit of racism and
maybe some prejudice they're the
favorites to love European
physiognomist was to look at the
similarity between a given person and an
animal so if you were similar to a bird
of prey
you were judged to be very aggressive if
you were similar to I don't know what
donkey you were supposed to be very
stubborn or what not so and there's not
much validity there's no validity to
this and no one has ever an shown there
is any validity to claims of this kind
now the fact that there used to be a
pseudo-scientific most likely fields
that claim that there are links between
face and
character and they were not pursuing
this science this they were not
following up with those claims with
valid scientific proofs and does not
mean that there can't be any links
between faith and character it just
means that they were not studying it
apparently in the in the right and
correct fashion which brings me to the
last point of my talk I hope that I
showed that not only we're living an
increasing amount of digital footprints
behind while using digital products and
services but also that computer
algorithms are getting better at turning
those digital footprints into accurate
predictions of our psychological traits
and future behavior which essentially
means that we're already living in the
post privacy world and then people would
say hey you know why if we just only
protected our data better using
legislation and technology and surely
our privacy could be protected well
guess what even the government's cannot
protect their data corporations cannot
protect their data how can you how can
we expect that people with less
resources less education and less
technological technical skills will be
able to successfully protect the data
not to mention that even if I was
somehow magically given full control
over my data there's still a lot that I
would like to share I want to tweet
freely and publicly I want most of my
facebook profile to be open to anyone
who can be bothered to look at it I want
to talk to you guys without covering my
face and then most of the people say
okay well then I guess we'll have to
deal with a bit of creepy marketing out
there maybe political marketing out
there but I'm afraid that it's not going
to be as
and as simple and as just creepy
marketing which brings me to this slide
you can see two composite faces here
those faces are created based on 100
images of males each and those males
they differ on a cycle one cycle
demographic trait can you guys guess
what is this psycho demographic trade
the difference between those two images
that's two for sure one of the
differences you can see is that one of
these groups tended to shave less but
also there will be differences in the
length of the nose in the shape of your
jaw there would be a difference in your
hairline and also propensity not only to
shave but also to wear head covers and
there will be slight differences with
facial expressions in chances of wearing
glasses and and so on so essentially not
only morphological traits differ between
those groups but also things that they
do to their faces like shaving or
wearing a head cover so what is the
psycho demographic trade the difference
between them well there might be
actually a bias in their voting behavior
as well which you can see here as you
can see 100 images of homosexual males
in 100 images of heterosexual males and
it turns out that very simple again a
computer algorithm in fact an algorithm
that has not been trained to reveal your
sexual orientation an algorithm that has
been trained to detect face can
recognize between straight and gay a
male with an accuracy when presented
with an image of a straight and gay male
with an accuracy of an area under the
curve of over 90% given five facial
images and around 0.8 given one facial
image now this accuracy
comparable with diagnostic accuracy of
our state-of-the-art Parkinson disease
diagnostic tools or our state-of-the-art
breast cancer diagnostic tools those are
people who self-identified they're gay
but we used people from liberal country
and relatively non homophobic country in
this case United States and of course if
you go to other countries then the much
lower their we much lower a fraction of
people who are willing to publicly come
out with the sexual orientation which is
the main problem that is being
Illustrated by this paper if you look at
this map it shows you in which countries
around the world being outed as a gay
person means that you can be sentenced
even to death which illustrates clearly
that losing our privacy is not just a
matter of some creepy marketing but is
literally a matter of life and death so
just to summarize i'm not against the
regulation and technologies that are out
there to protect our privacy we
definitely definitely should think about
those as long as they do not become a
distraction as long as they do not
create an illusion if if we just vote
for the right politicians and choose the
right technology that somehow will able
to go back to the times where it was in
our power to decide where i want to
reveal to you my political views or my
sexual orientation the sooner we accept
the fact that we are living in a post
privacy world and it's just going to
become even easier to reveal our
intimate rates without our consent
the sooner we can sit down and start
having a conversation how to make sure
that such a post privacy world is - the
habitable and
nice place to live and I should stop
here and open the floor for questions
[Applause]
detect somebody bluffing in poker by
algorithmically I in fact there is a
startup that boasts that are doing
exactly that based just on a picture of
the other video of the face I wouldn't
know but given that computers got that
come those algorithms based on short
videos of human faces got better at
predicting emotion of others than human
judges I would say that the accuracy is
going to be higher than the accuracy of
human players now this is really
remarkable because look at look at this
problem in the following way our
evolution shaped us in such a way as to
make us really good at judging other
people's emotion being able to quickly
detect when someone when your spouse or
your enemy or just a random person you
met is angry or happy just based on
their face was crucial to our survival
the biggest enemy of a human being is
another human being the biggest assets
of a human being is again another human
being for quite a long time we managed
to put ourselves in such a situation as
to basically make our social
interactions the most important ones for
the survival and evolutionary success
and yet after only few years of
development of computer algorithms that
specifically computer algorithms in the
computer vision space we're now having
computers that can beat us at this core
human task of judging other people's
emotion to what extent as you describe
the populations of the responders can
you stratify those
and I use me and identify
characteristics that define those
populations or subpopulations
populations of people who are better at
judging versus versus judging is so
there's definitely there's definitely
this this research is definitely going
on and in fact if someone is really bad
at judging other people's emotions
there's a whole range of psychological
disorders are being that kind of one of
their symptoms is that you lack an
ability to accurately judge other
people's emotions but one interesting
fact here and I forgot the actual
numbers is that whenever you run those
models predicting emotion or predicting
psychological traits from faces
predicting future behavior deciding how
likely you were to commit a crime after
you're released from prison whenever you
train these models predicting how likely
are going to relapse when you're
released from psychiatric ward now when
you compare the accuracy of these models
we have accuracy of humans what happens
is that even the most accurate human is
not coming close to the predictive model
and we know it since the 60s so much of
this research in M way simpler form was
conducted in the sixties when Lou
Goldberg and it was actually with books
written about it in 57 and then there
was another interesting book in 60 F 4
and it was summarizing a huge body of
research which was in this and again I'm
a psychologist I will be mostly
interested in research related to
psychology and this particular line of
research was looking at predict whether
a person released from a psychiatric
hospital will have to be readmitted
after a short period of time and the
idea was hey let's try to improve the
system so we don't let people go that we
have to readmit them immediately
afterwards and what happened is that
they induced this research they would
collect facts about the patient they
would give those facts to train
psychiatrists as well as non trained
people and then give the same facts to
and linear regression and it turns out
that no psychiatrist could ever beat
linear regression at predicting which
person is going to be readmitted to the
hospital
and now we'll tell you more and it shows
you how how silly we really and biased
we humans are that once this was
discovered Lew Goldberg who's running
this study he thought okay let me run
another study he went back to a
different group of psychiatrist and he
said look this is a paper showing you
that no psychiatrist can ever beat the
accuracy of this algorithm when
predicting where a person is going to be
readmitted or not so now let me give you
the results of this algorithm for these
100 people and now you please make a
decision you can use the results of an
algorithm or make your own decision and
what a psychiatrist would psychiatrists
did they'll be like okay I will follow
the advice of an algorithm but in this
case no I will change the decision of an
algorithm guess what accuracy went down
so even if you think oh in this case I'm
smarter than a computer guess what you
are not actually using very simple set
of variables like symptoms that people
had how many times they were readmitted
before the gender age bunch of very
simple indicators when you are it's not
only US government the Chinese
government is German government is
Israeli government is probably any
government that that is serious about
about their security that are trying to
in
Clemente those methods and this
technology very much like virtually any
other technology has both risks brings
both risks of abuse and benefits right
if you let me let me give you let me
give you four examples if I told if I
told the room of psychologists that now
we should use those algorithms and we
know from the sixties that those
Oligocene to the 60s that algorithms
those algorithms are better than a human
psychologist at predicting future
behavior and future behavior of
psychological disease than people -
let's say judge the risk that a kid's
would commit crime psychologists would
shout at me there's absolutely how
dare I suggesting that we use such
methods minority reports but wait a
moment we are doing exactly this already
we're using school counselors they are
looking there at kids in if you are if
you are going to a good school in a good
neighborhood you probably have a school
psychologist that would work with
children and try to spot children with
behavioral issues and then spend more
time working with them to protect well
other kids society and the kids from
themselves from let's say behavioral
problems increased aggression and so on
now the problem is that again time of a
psychology is expensive also we know
that algorithms are more accurate at
making those judgments that is said that
this psychologist and also we know that
is especially important when it comes to
diverse populations we know for instance
that if you have a Caucasian person they
will be able to judge a motion of other
Caucasian people much better than people
from other ethnic groups it relates to
exposure differences in facial features
and so on and algorithms can be much
more easily designed in such a way as to
be equally accurate across different age
groups gender genders ethnic groups and
and so on
but the centaurian pretty creative issue
how many simple every psychologist sees
maybe ten thousand patients in the
career maybe probably three how many
data samples did the algorithms I think
in the in this case of this research
from the 50s the the sample size was
more like 150 to 200 that the algorithm
was trained on but look this is of
course one could argue the game is not
fair because an algorithm judging
personality was able to look at hundreds
of thousands of pictures and also the
algorithm knew what their scores we're
whereas we when we go about our lives
and we see other people we never see
their personalities course or maybe very
rarely see person I this course so one
could argue our brains are not as well
trained as computers are but well guess
what because our brains I just don't
have the capacity to look at ten
thousand pictures and ten thousand
personality scores and probably will be
inhumane to request that any of us has
to do it so there this is one of the
reasons I believe that algorithms are
going to have an upper hand when it
comes to predictions of this kind wait
actually because this reminded me
retraining the the experts in those lou
goldberg studies from the 50s and 60s
they try to train humans so they would
when they made a decision very much like
when do you train the model the
scientist would immediately say your
decision was right or wrong and have an
exile and whatnot and people's ability
to make accurate decisions would grow a
bit but then would really quickly
flatten out again whereas the beauty of
a computer to improve its accuracy would
grow much further and the its accuracy
resulting Acuras will be much higher it
seems to me this is a classic case of
Albert of not being able to explain why
it concluded anything linear regression
sorry linear company
you know multiple properties is the most
naive weighting of all of these
properties so I'm surprised it even did
well at all compared with something more
sophisticated which would you know
figure out the weights based on some
training set which we would do today so
I mean I'm just wondering if if this had
been an inference kind of engine
if the psychologist would have done
better at learning what the algorithm
was concluding they'd start and it would
train the better yes and of course and
we're doing this you know the the great
part of being a scientist is to try to
answer a question why and then educate
people about why to help them make more
accurate decisions now the problem is
that very often a beauty of a human
being to make an accurate decision is
limited by the ability to learn about
all of the wise or being constantly
published in scientific journals now
there's also another aspect that is in
trend of didn't really mention it but
let me build on your question which is
we very often insist that we need to
understand why before we make a decision
and this is beautifully illustrated by
the justice system where we know that
the algorithm can predict with higher
accuracy than a human being
what are given a person is likely to
reoffend or not which basically means
that you can greatly reduce the
population of prey of prison a prison
population you can offer these people
freedom that are in prison for no good
measure because we are the algorithm
will already give you higher accuracy in
predicting they're know and they they
pose no risk to the society so we know
that algorithms are more accurate
there's a lot of evidence including
coming from these very departments on
this on this front but now many people
would say well ok but we do not
understand exactly how the algorithm
works because it's this complicated you
know AI based algorithm so we cannot
ever use it well my response to it would
be hey think about what we're doing at
the moment we're asking a judge to make
this decision and guess what
we have no idea how judge is arriving at
this decision because we know that we
have very little understanding about how
the human brain works in fact we have
lesson we understand much less how the
human brain works compared with an
average deep neural network that we can
train these days and the judge will tell
you something and you just make stuff up
and this is what psychology is about
that we very often in most cases we have
very little at our access a I can make
it up to yes yes that's probably true
but at the end of the day we have met we
can measure and we can show that AI is
making decisions are more fair and more
accurate and they can save lives and
increase well-being and this is showing
information few results today because
deep neural networks many other problems
I found out from a particular judge that
if you send innocent people to the
gallows and as just a much and deterrent
on future crime there's if you something
guilty guy to the gallows
it's a great point and I'm sure that's
the algorithms will be doing this as
well I think I should because I know
that my time was limited to 545 I'm
super happy to stay and answer the
questions but we should also perhaps
you